bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du prochain produit de htc le htc u 12 u
nous plus pas réellement quel nom il
aura en attendant un produit qui
pourrait être intéressant mais qui à la
fois sans avoir un train de retard mais
bon ça on va les tailles et maintenant
[Musique]
htc c'est une marque qui est plutôt cool
qui a vraiment des bons produits mais
qui pourtant n'allez pas vraiment à se
démarquer et arrive pas à voir un match
vraiment du point de vue du consommateur
parce que moi je trouve que htc a
vraiment des produits qui tiennent la
route
j'en ai déjà testé plusieurs d'ailleurs
testé un projet qui n'est pas encore
sorti en france qui sortira peut-être
jamais en france htc du monde
eyes que j'ai pu rencontrer au mwc à
barcelone et je trouve que
malheureusement cette gamme la u2 et l'a
probablement là u12 a toujours un petit
peu un train de retard et manque un
petit peu de séduction il va pas
forcément séduire tout le monde annonce
est pas si c'est votre cas dites moi
tout de suite si vous avez un produit de
htc si htc pourrait vous intéresser s'il
vous séduisent oui ou non ont marqué
tout ça en commentaire en tout cas ce
htc pourrait être annoncée au mois de
mai on connaît pas le nom du 12 une
douce plus ça reste un petit peu à voir
il ya déjà des rumeurs qui circulent qui
viendrait d'un accessoiriste qui aurait
effectivement laissé sortir quelques
images de ce futur produit alors du
point de vue des écrans déjà on devrait
avoir un écran 6 pouces avec une
résolution qhd plus de 1560 par 1440
pixels au format 18 9e une dalle ipes
lcd sans encoches htc a fait le choix de
ne pas m'être d'encoches comme beaucoup
de produits sur android actuellement
donc un design vraiment avec quelque
chose de très profilée sur l'eau et ça
c'est plutôt pas mal
à l'arrière un design assez brillant un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales situé au
centre de l'appareil un double capteur
de sel fille à l'avant 8 mégapixels
également un double capteur à l'arrière
cette fois-ci 16 + 12 mégapixels côté
processeur de tourner avec un qualcomm
snapdragon 845 donc quelque chose de
très performant couplé à 4 gigas de ram
et qu'on va retrouver en 64 go de
stockage ou 128 giga de stockage une
batterie de 3420 milliampères heures une
certification ip68 le déverrouillage
avec le visage qu'on appelle le fun loc
vous allez pouvoir avoir une mémoire
étendue grâce à une carte micro sd a
priori une version avec une seule carte
sim ou une version avec une double carte
sim
le to qui tourne sous android et 8.00
avec une surcouche 110 et
malheureusement pas deux prises jack moi
c'est une grande déception je suis pas
ça qui va changer en tout cas la phase
ii pro de ce produit mais pas de prise
jack
alors moi je suis pas convaincu parce
que j'ai fait
mon de ce qu'on voit des images qui
circulent sont peut-être pas les images
officielles attention parce que une fois
de plus on est dans la rumeur on est
dans des infos qui circulent dans des
fuites
est ce que ce sont les vraies images oui
ou non en tout cas si ce sont les vraies
images je suis pas convaincu par ce que
il faut de plus moi je suis pas piquer
par une marque plutôt qu'une autre j'ai
effectivement un iphone parce que ça
fait longtemps je tombe sur un os j'ai
toutes mes applis dessus tout mes
sauvegardes et que j'ai pas envie de
m'embêter sinon ya plein d'autres
marques qui me séduire et sur lesquels
gérer mais par feignantise pour
l'instant je reste avec mon iphone 6
aces mais par contre je suis pas du tout
bloqué là dessus je trouve qu'il ya
plein de marques qui sont super mais je
sais pas pourquoi htc
j'ai un problème avec eux je crains pas
cette marque je peux pas dire qu'ils
font du mauvais boulot parce que d'un
point de vue technique ça tient la route
mais je trouve qu'ils ont pas le truc
séduisant il leur manque vraiment une
pâte qui fait que ces produits on en est
de se dire ah ouais ce produit je le
veux ce produit est désirable
ce produit hyper sexy à mon avis c'est
vraiment ce qui manque à cette marque
parce que que ce soit le 11 ou les ce
qu'on a pu avoir après les u11 life news
lesquels qui compagnie peu importe on a
eu plein d'autres mais je trouve que
vraiment il leur manque un côté sexy y
manque une patine dans quelque chose de
séduisant et j'ai bien peur qu avec ce
but 12e 12 plus ce soit exactement la
même chose c'est-à-dire un produit
auquel on peut rien reprocher parce
qu'il est performant parce que du point
de vue technos ça marche mais du point
de vue esthétique du point de vue une
ovation
il manque quelque chose et je trouve que
c'est vraiment août aujourd'hui en tout
cas ce qui est dommage
avec la marque htc j'ai eu des produits
htc il ya très longtemps à l'époque où
les dinosaures exister et je trouvais
que c'était pas mal
il y avait des choses qui se détacher un
peu et depuis quelques années je trouve
vraiment que htc a du mal à innover a du
mal à proposer vraiment des produits qui
sortent de l'ordinaire et qui sortent du
lot je peux pas dire que si vous avez
acheté un produit htc vous serez déçu
parce que je ne pense pas mais je trouve
que malgré tout c'est toujours un peu en
demi-teinte par rapport à la concurrence
quand on voit que des produits avec des
constructeurs chinois qui arrive que ce
soit au tour down the swatch hiromi
honor compagne et tous les autres qui
vous propose des choses mais c'est
vraiment un petit peu d'aller sur des
produits un petit peu plus sexy y en a
plein j'ai vu au mwc que j'ai pu voir à
droite à gauche
ce soit aux crs aussi à las vegas j'ai
vu plein de produits que je trouve hyper
séduisant et malheureusement je trouve
que htc a du mal un petit peu à prendre
on de ce virage là et à se positionner
alors est-ce qu'ils ont un problème de
recherche et développement est ce qu'ils
se basent sur des standards qui sont pas
les standards actuels je ne sais pas
réellement ce qui se passe du point de
vue de cette marque mais je trouve en
tout cas que il ya un problème
d'innovation un problème aujourd'hui
pour avoir des produits séduisants et à
la limite ce qu'on peut vraiment dire
qui est très bien pour un c est ce qu il
cherche pas à faire des copies n'est pas
le copient ce qu'on appelle des mythes
ou comme les autres à se dit ah bah je
vais vous faire une copie de l'iphone 10
ou vous faire une tombe d'un samsung
galaxy ou autre non au contraire ils
gardent leur adn mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui leur adn qui n'est pas
séduisant et c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment ce qui est dommage
et j'espère que toutes les rumeurs à
toutes les infos qu'on a là dessus en
tout cas d'un point de vue esthétique ce
n'est pas réellement ce qu'on va
retrouver parce que une fois de plus je
serai déçu et c'est embêtant de dire ça
parce que tu as un constructeur qui
malgré tout s'engage au niveau de ses
smartphones à vouloir faire son mieux il
ya vouloir faire des beaux smartphones
mais je trouve qu'ils ont malgré tout un
train de retard
je sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez un produit acheté
c'est ce que vous en avez déjà eu un
est-ce que vous avez un u 11 par exemple
est-ce que vous avez un urroz life est
ce que vous les avez essayé ce que
voulait trouver intéressant oui non
est-ce qu'il tourne bien est-ce que vous
êtes satisfait est ce que vous compte
trouver que au contraire
l'adn d'acheter cessé de prendre le
contre-pied tous reste de son foot des
modes et de dire nous notre produit
c'est ça il plaît il plaît pas au risque
de se casser la gueule
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire parce
que ça va être un débat passionné et
passionnant j'en suis persuadé merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo bien
évidemment rester connecté parce que dès
que le produit sera annoncé et dès que
j'en aurai l'occasion je le prendrais
dans les mains on le testera dont on va
reparler donc vous inquiétez pas on va
pas s'arrêter là dessus et on va pouvoir
aller un peu plus loin pour essayer de
comprendre un petit peu ce qui se passe
du côté d'acheter ses marques et moi en
tout cas toutes vos questions toutes vos
suggestions et tous vos avis en
commentaires comme d'hab regrettable et
s'est désolé pousse à vous abonner
parce qu'à plein de choses qui vont être
super cool qui arrivent des surprises ni
pas plus rester à rester connectés à
très bientôt vous embrasse
soyez sages
[Musique]